[Musique]
francoeur robinet dans son caddie ce
matin bonjour monsieur le préfet bonjour
maurice fulton merci d'être avec nous en
poste depuis le 19 juillet à peine trois
mois et déjà hier des milliers de
martiniquais dans les rues de
fort-de-france vous demandant de rentrer
chez vous car dit-il le préfet de
martinique complètement dépassé par les
événements dans cette question des
contrats et des frappes robin
gardez-vous le contrôle de la situation
ce qu'ils expriment sont évidemment des
inquiétudes qui sont fortes quatre mille
personnes dans les rues c'est après
occupe évidemment et le préfet le
gouvernement ça correspond une vraie
inquiétude c'est celle de l'importance
prise par les emplois aidés dans
l'économie martiniquaise et je crois
qu'il est du devoir effectivement du
préfet de maintenir le dialogue et puis
d'essayer de trouver des lieux une des
solutions en liaison bien sûr et grave
j'ai l'impression que c'est une cocotte
minute ce qui se passe en ce moment
c'est la situation est très vive mais
pourquoi aller vivre ça fait trente
trois ans qu'il ya des contrats aidés
depuis
1984 on est dans cette économie de
contrats aidés donc beaucoup de gens
sont concernées toutes les familles
martinique et martiniquaise ont eu des
contrats aidés et donc il est normal que
l'annoncent de la diminution des
contrats aidés préoccupe je le comprends
c'est de la société de de l'inconscience
de là comment comment qualifier
l'attitude du gouvernement je sais bien
que vous êtes le représentant de ce
gouvernement ici mais il n'a pas
l'impression d'avoir et il est tout
simplement une balle dans les pieds là
est de recréer les conditions de
mouvements février mais à 2009 là que la
question est la suivante je vous ai dit
ça fait trente trois ans qu'on fait des
contrats aidés est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que la situation du chômage
s'est améliorée en france et en
martinique
non évidemment et donc ce que souhaite
le gouvernement sait évoluer vers des
formes plus pérenne d'emploi une
meilleure insertion professionnelle que
les emplois aidés ne garantissent pas
alors ce que le gouvernement a dit et il
l'a pris en compte c'est qu'il
maintiendra des contrats et des
outre-mer mais ce qu'il veut c'est
organiser la transition vers des formes
meilleur d'insertion professionnelle
comme expliquait ce matin que
l'intersyndicale a plutôt l'impression
que que vous faites le grand écart
monsieur le préfet que deux côtés
effectivement d'antan le premier
ministre dira que en outre-mer ans n'est
pas concerné par les dispositifs mais
qu'ici on revenu sur les chiffres c'est
une impression c'est le message qui ne
passe pas bien écouté ce que je voudrais
c'est qu'on regarde les propositions que
j'ai faites hier j'ai fait trois
propositions
le renouvellement à la hauteur de 2016
de l'ensemble des contrats aidés de
l'éducation nationale la totalité les
920 du rectorat les 355 de ce qu'on
appelle le périscolaire c'est à dire les
communes et les associations et les 370
des personnels techniques employées par
la ctm qui assure la cantine le
nettoyage c'est il ya la situation dans
l'éducation assure l'éducation nationale
ça c'est clair c'est ont reconduit à la
hauteur de 2016 pour ce qui concerne les
autres contrats en dehors de l'éducation
nationale j'ai proposé la chose suivante
une solution pour chaque contrat aidé
mais on commence à organiser la
transition vers ces formes meilleur
d'insertion professionnelle donc ce que
j'ai proposé c'est avec les maires de
regarder les 80 contrats aidés qu'ils
ont à renouveler pour voir contrats
aidés par contrat aidé s'il n'y a pas de
meilleure solution que le contrat aidé
même chose avec les associations et a340
et un contrat aidé est donc le troisième
engagement que j'ai pris c'est on
regarde ces ensembles on y va contrats
aidés par contrat aidé et s'il n'y a pas
de solution je me suis engagé à
reconduire bensaïd et fort qu robin
comment expliquer qu hier soir en
discutant avec les uns et les autres à
bien au niveau de la terre syndicales au
niveau des élus on a plutôt l'impression
qu'avec le préfet joue la carte de
l'enfumage le préfet il est là pour
faire des propositions pour faire
évoluer les choses et aussi pour mettre
en oeuvre la politique du gouvernement
je pense sincèrement que orienter la
politique de l'emploi vers des formes
meilleur d'insertion c'est une bonne
chose le préfet il est là aussi
effectivement pour discuter avec les
manifestants il ya une question qui a
émergé depuis hier soir qui n'a pas
était formulée du moins pas aussi
explicitement pendant les rencontres que
j'ai eues avec eux est-ce que l'année
scolaire sera garanti 2017 2018 la
réponse est oui je profite de votre
émission pour le dire très clairement
l'année scolaire 2017 2018 pour les
contrats aidés sera assurée dans
l'éducation nationale avec les contrats
aidés de l'éducation nationale avec les
contrats aidés de l'ensemble du secteur
de l'éducation nationale estime que les
mesures que vous proposez ce sera juste
un moment de respiration jusqu'au 31
décembre de cette année un micro 1er
janvier est bien cette mobilisation
pourrait repartir parce que les
conditions n'ont pas été réunies et que
tout le monde sera sous tension toujours
ou leur petit coin alors je viens de
vous répondre pour l'éducation nationale
de contrats aidés vont courir sur un
évidement sur l'ensemble de l'année
scolaire et même au delà puisque un
contrat aidé c'est généralement 12 - il
faut lui il faut le savoir et
deuxièmement le premier ministre a
répondu par avance puisqu'il a indiqué
sur l'année 2018 que le volume de
contrats aidés de l'outre-mer il a fait
cette déclaration samedi dernier le
volume de contrats aidés de l'outre-mer
serait garanti alors pourquoi fred
michel giroux le maire du saint-esprit
sur nos antennes télé disait que le
préfet n'avait rien compris et pourquoi
ils se sentent était à discuter encore
comme ça avec l'intersyndicale moi quand
j'ai effectivement 4000 personnes dans
fort de france quand je vois la reprise
je comprend une chose c'est qu'il ya une
vraie inquiétude et je la respecte c'est
les manifestations les inquiétudes je
les respecte fortement et donc j'essaye
de formuler des solutions en liaison
bien sûr avec les manifestants avec
leurs les revendications et bien sûr en
appliquant la politique du gouvernement
je voulais dit cela fait 33 ans que nous
faisons les contrats aidés et on ne peut
pas dire que ce soit satisfaisant franck
robine ça fait trois mois que vous êtes
en martinique 1 vous prenez connaissance
avec les réalités martiniquaise vous
fait remonter ce que vous voyez en
martinique vous dites aux gens de bercy
vous dites aux gens du ministère de
l'intérieur vous dit on au cabinet du
premier ministre ce que vous ressentez
ce que vous voyez d'ailleurs pu
ressentez-vous ce que je ressens c'est
on en a parlé c'est l'inquiétude moi ça
me laisse pas indifférent je pense que
la martinique et martinique et les
martiniquaises ils ont une vitalité très
forte je suis arrivé la veille du tour
des yoles la martinique
et parallèlement là on a le contraste
qui s'exprime c'est vrai qu'il 20% de
chômage c'est un handicap lourd il faut
regarder les choses en face moi j'ai
quand même sa remontée jeu oui bien sûr
bien sûr c'est que c'est bon qu'est-ce
qu'on veut répondre lorsque vous barbe à
paris et que vous expliquer cette
réalité est ce qu on me répond c'est que
je suis aussi là pour organiser les
choses organiser la transition pour ce
qui concerne la politique de l'emploi la
transition vers des formes plus durables
d'emplois c'est tout à fait normal c'est
le rôle du préfet de faire l'interface
de garder le dialogue de bien sentir la
réalité des choses j'essaye aussi
d'aller sur le terrain je suis allé le
jour suite aux cyclones voir les
bananiers voir les producteurs de fruits
et légumes je suis allé voir les
restaurateurs du carbet pour essayer de
leur fournir des réponses et puis je
maintient un contact bien évidemment
avec tous ceux qui sont inquiets de la
diminution des attaques et de cette
situation je suis inquiet de cette
situation oui bien sûr je veux je ce que
je demande encore une fois c'est que les
propositions que les fêtes soient
regardées à l'aune de la réalité il y à
une solution j'ai pris un engagement
très clair c'est que pour le cas où on
ne trouverait pas de solution hors
éducation nationale les contrats aidés
serait reconduit je crois que c'est
assez clair
je demande à ce qu'on veut pas être
suffisant puisque les manifestations
s'organisent des convois vont converger
vers fort de france écoutez je crois
qu'il faut toujours maintenir le
dialogue moi je comprends le droit de
manifester il est garanti dans notre
pays et c'est heureux et une le rôle du
préfet c'est bien de maintenir le
dialogue avec tous ceux qui organisent
les manifestations
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
franck robine rappel vous êtes le préfet
de martinique et c'était votre première
dans l'émission sans crédit bonne
journée merci à vous
[Musique]